welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and a few easy to miss details and
she-hulk are pointing to a critical
period in mcu history when bruce banner
and tony stark were tinkering on some
dangerous stuff and thanks to rocket
money for sponsoring today's video more
about them later we all know what
happened the last time these new lab
partners were left unsupervised we're
mad scientists
we're monsters buddy
we've got to own it
these puppets
[Music]
ah
yes tony and bruce and their toy ruined
everything so how fitting is it that
this iron man mask that jen walters
finds in tony stark's beach house is
that same scarred face on that iron
legion drone that ultron initially
housed himself in when he first
introduced himself to the avengers i
don't think this is just an easter egg
or nostalgic decor by tony and bruce i
think this is an indicator of what tony
and bruce might have been working on
during their several months together so
let's discuss hulk in iron man's mystery
lab experiment during the blip because
let's be real tony wouldn't have left
pregnant pepper potts just to help bruce
become smart hulk for 18 whole months
otherwise it would have been tony
sleeping in that tent on the farm not
morgan in she-hulk jenna wakes up
post-hulk out in a mexican beach house
where she changes into tony's led
zeppelin shirt and waters upstairs
passing a few easter eggs including
hulk's sakar helmet from thor ragnarok
and this iron man mask
[Music]
yes you heard the avengers theme there
though this mask was not part of an iron
man suit its scarring and edge are
exactly that of the iron legion drone
from age of ultron the one that got
scarred by acid from protesters in
sokovia and later gets hijacked by
ultron's ai when he first presents
himself to the avengers in avengers
tower after this downstairs bruce tells
his cousin but this is where i spent a
blip fixing myself and integrating the
hulk banner identities in this tiny
beach house lab yeah yeah tony built it
for me a few years ago
tony stark he used to joke that it was
alone and that one day he just swing by
and take it back he has stark industries
insignias everywhere on the buzz sauce
in the torture room and on that device
on the desk behind jen earlier on this
lab is suggested to be the gamma lab
that bruce mentioned in endgame 18
months in a gamma lab i put the brains
and the brawn together
and now look at me and later in the
episode of she-hulk bruce indicated that
he and tony spent a lot of the blip just
drinking
you built this bar
by hand yeah me and tony now tony mostly
drank sat around complaining about steve
oh steve
it's a good time during a hard time now
tony could not have been drinking with
bruce for the full 18 months during the
blip that it took for bruce to become
smart hulk morgan stark is aged 4 when
we meet her in avengers end game
according to the official screenplay
meaning tony and pepper probably would
have conceived her around eight months
into the blip and then after pepper
became pregnant i doubt tony would have
had as many weekends in mexico with
bruce so those first eight months before
pepper became pregnant were probably
tony still recovering from his weakened
state after returning to earth and
endgame when he was still bitter over
the avengers missteps but then sometime
during these months he got bruce set up
in this lab on his own so that tony
could return in new york to retire and
build a family on the farm but we also
don't know for how long tony had this
lab before thanos got to earth because
when you re-watch age of ultron there is
one line that reveals that tony and
bruce had planned on this mexican beach
house lifestyle for nearly a decade
earlier what if you were sipping
margaritas on a sun-dried speech turning
brown instead of green holy [ __ ] this is
exactly where bruce ends up in she-hulk
kicking it back jimmy buffett's style on
a sun-drenched beach even the vfx and
lighting on bruce's green skin brings
out those brown undertones my man is
getting tan i bring this up because it
often gets forgotten from age of ultron
how close tony and bruce were these two
were the mad scientists who cooked up
what became ultron they completed the
synthazoid that became vision so when
you add the time between the first two
avengers movies and the time during the
blip it's kinda implied that bruce and
tony might have spent more time together
than any other avenger pairing because
let's also not forget how the entire
events of iron man 3 were described in
detail by tony stark to bruce banner who
was revealed to the audience of tony's
voiceover throughout the film in the
post-credits scene these two were very
close confidants there are lots of
reasons to save money maybe you want to
save up to buy a new nerdy shirt to show
up what a fan you are or you want to
take a trip to a convention to show what
a fan you are or you want to remodel
your house to look like stan lee's head
to show what a fan you are you've all
heard me talk about true bill my
favorite personal finance app for
managing subscriptions budgeting
lowering bills and tracking your
expenses well they recently became
rocket money rocket money is everything
you loved about true build with a fresh
look and feel rocket money lets you
easily cancel unwanted subscriptions
with just a tap you can also monitor
your credit score find out steps you can
take to improve your credit score and
set budgets for yourself there's even a
tool to help you set up a smart savings
account to automatically set aside money
for special occasions in case you're
saving up for a full body photorealistic
tattoo of stan lee's body to go on your
body more than 3.4 million people use
rocket money to help get the most out of
their money you can try out the new
rocket money app for free or upgrade to
premium to unlock more features want to
see for yourself simply head to
rocketmoney.com new rockstars so it's
just super interesting to me that in the
early months of the blip tony decided to
get away with his buddy bruce to a
remote beach house lab in mexico if tony
mentioned sippy margaritas on a beach
early on during age of ultron's run time
it suggests to me that he already owned
this beach house property as a remote
lab another site where he could test out
experiments that he wanted to keep under
wraps away from the prying eyes of the
rest of the avengers a place that tony
even kept off the books when the
avengers located to their compound
upstate at the end of that film so let's
remember tony's mindset at the beginning
of the blip it wasn't good i saw this
coming a few years back i had a vision i
didn't want to believe it that what we
needed
was a pseudo-armor around the world
remember that whether it impacted our
precious freedoms or not that's what we
needed yes tony was recalling his suit
of armor around the world hope from age
of ultron he's basically saying if we
had ultron or rather what i intended
ultron to be we would have been
protected from thanos so yeah at the
start of the blip tony was totally
thinking maybe i wasn't wrong about
ultron maybe the problem with ultron was
the one foreign variable i had no
control over the reason our otherwise
perfect experiment of vision ended up
being such a liability that doomed us
all in infinity war the problem was the
infinity stone so now during these blip
years after thanos used the stones to
destroy the stones tony could now
convince banner that ultron 2.0 is worth
a try because there's no mind stone to
corrupt the technology and be that ghost
in the machine especially since bruce
just learned from shuri that an ai
synthesiod could theoretically function
without an infinity stone the structure
is polymorphic
right we had to attach each neuron non
non-sequentially why didn't you just
reprogram the synapses to work
collectively
because we didn't think of it surely not
having enough time to extract the mind
stone from vision was one of the
avengers conditional failures that led
to thanos success so naturally bruce and
tony would totally replay it again and
again in their heads and could conclude
wait if the mind stone was that rogue ai
that led to ultron instead of division
what is to stop us from building another
automated suit of armor around this
world to prevent this from ever
happening again and by the way there
would be no way for tony and bruce to
know this but what if episode 8 showed
us how effective a final form ultron
would be against thanos i know i know
ultron was using a stone there but
ultron was far more effective with his
one stone than thanos was with five
suggesting that when stones are removed
from the equation ultron is totally
deadlier than thanos's so i think that
in the early years of the blip tony and
bruce were trying to resurrect the
ultron initiative one could argue ultron
is still alive based on those glowing
eyes in the ultron century head in the
dodc's storage and spider-man homecoming
assets that tony would likely have
access to at that point in history since
he was the one funding that dodc
operation so either bruce and tony kept
ultron's original face upstairs to
remind them to keep a morality clause
part of the coding or they might have
just given up on their efforts and
enshrined that ultron face to scare them
from ever trying this again and you can
imagine after that bruce might have said
well if we could control the world we
could at least try to control ourselves
leading the bruce is 18 months toward
finally gaining control over his hulk
outs i mean you could say that this mask
is just an easter egg but i say ultron
lives and she-hulk did just prove that
tony stark never truly made it out of
the age of ultron you can follow me on
tik-tok instagram and twitter
subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
you